Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 8, where we're going to talk about function libraries.
In this lecture we're going to build a library of ancient algorithms.
And the ancient algorithms we're going to implement in our library are Euclid's algorithm, the greatest common divisor from about 330 BC.
We're going to implement Newton's square root algorithm.
This was actually developed in ancient Babylon under Hammurabi around 1800 BC, but Newton always gets credit for it.
And finally we're going to find a better approximation for pi than the fraction 355 over 113.
Now each of these is going to need an indefinite loop.
We have two kinds of indefinite loops. We have while condition, and that's generally preferred. It's generally easier to understand and maintain.
And we have a do while condition. We use that seldom, but we use that in one of our algorithms here.
Now each of these algorithms also uses a new kind of indefinite loop called a limit loop.
The loops we looked at in the last lecture were sentinel loops. We were looking until we found a period.
Here we're going to use a loop where we reduce a number to zero, or where we do a couple of approximations,
where we do some bisection or some non-convergence tests. Are we going closer to zero or further away from zero?
Those kinds of things. These are used very much in finance. They're used in graphics. They're used in the sciences.
And so we're not only going to learn how to write a function library, but we're going to look at loops, continue looking at loops.
So the library we're going to talk about, first we need to define some functions.
For the compiler to compile your code, the compiler needs to know the argument types and the return types.
And so there are several ways we can go about doing that. First, we could define the function before we use it.
Now we'd only do this for the very smallest programs. So you have a main function, and up above the main function,
you write the definition for the function that you want to call inside main.
For programs that are slightly larger, what we can use, now the problem with defining the functions before you use them,
is that if one function calls another function, it has to be defined before it is called in the other function.
And so it's quite difficult to order the functions if there are multiple functions,
which is why this is only useful for small, one-off kind of programs.
However, if you want to define the functions and use them in the same program,
what you can do is you can declare the functions before the main function,
and then you can define the functions after the main functions.
Now this is useful for small programs where you want to keep everything in one file.
The third way to handle this is to separately compile the functions,
and then link them together with the main function, the function that calls it.
And that's the last, it's the most flexible, and that's what we're going to do from now on.
So go ahead and open your algo lib folder in your IDE, and we'll look at several different files.
So here's algo, algo lib,
and so here's my ICO8 algo lib.
So I have algo.cpp, algo.h, makefile, and tester.cpp.
Let me open the makefile here, and I'll move the makefile down to the end.
So let me talk about what these three files are, four files are.
Algo.h is our interface file.
It will contain the prototypes for all of the functions in our library,
and it will contain the documentation.
Algo.cpp is the implementation file.
That is where we will put our source code.
Tester.cpp is our client or testing file.
It is the file that will be calling the functions.
Algo.cpp will be defining the functions, and algo.h will be declaring the functions.
Finally, we have something that needs to put all of these parts together,
and that is our makefile, and that is the project file that we're going to use to put everything together.
Now you'll notice there are a couple of other files inside there,
cs150check.cpp and cs150check.h,
and those are files we'll use for the testing framework.
So notice we have several different files inside here,
and we need to put all of those together, and the job of doing that will be the makefile.
We're going to start, though, with algo.h.
So before you do anything, you will need to create the interface for your classes,
or the interface for your functions.
These interfaces are going to be declarations, function declarations, or prototypes.
However, what would happen if we had this situation?
And so let me just put this code away, and down here in 150, let me create a couple of new files,
and I'll call this a.h,
and I'll create a new file here.
b.h,
and in a.h, I'm going to say include b.h,
and that's in b.h.
I'm going to include a.h,
and in a.h, I'm going to include b.h,
and finally in my example cpp here, I'm going to include a.h.
Now I haven't put anything inside the files, but I want to show you the problem.
So now, let me go ahead and open an integrated terminal.
Now, if I try and make example.cpp,
that actually worked.
Let's put something inside here.
Okay, so I'll put a prototype in a.h, and I'll put another prototype
in b.h.
Example.cpp has included a.h,
and I'm going to say g++ example.cpp out example.
Okay, so this is the error I want you to see.
So notice a.h tries to include b,
b tries to include a, a tries to include b again,
b tries to include a again, and so forth.
Now you might think, well, why would anybody do that?
That just seems incredibly silly.
Nobody would in fact do that.
But in fact, if I look at this header, iostream,
it needs to have the declarations of the functions that print out strings.
So if we look inside iostream.h, or iostream,
we'd see that it includes the header for string.
Then, when we look at the string class,
we'd see that it needs to have a function, like getline,
that needs to know about the iostream classes,
so it will include iostream.
So it's exactly the same as what I did here with a and b.
And so we have to have some way of preventing that,
and that is what we get with what are called header guards.
So open up algol.h, and I'll show you what a header guard looks like.
It consists of preprocessor declarations that say
#if end if. That means if not defined,
then we use the name of the file, typically in all uppercase,
so algo, not a period, but an underscore for h.
And if that is not defined, then go ahead and define it.
So #define algol.h.
And then at the end, endif.
Now, the first time this header file is discovered,
algol.h will not be defined,
and so we will run the stuff between the if endif
and the endif at the end,
the #if endif and the #endif at the end.
The first line inside that is define algol.h,
and so that allows the compiler to run it,
remember it, just for this run.
So the next time it sees this,
the #if endif algol.h will be false,
and all the inner part will be skipped,
which would include some other file.
Let's put our name on this as well.
And...
Okay, so these are header guards,
they prevent multiple inclusions.
They prevent multiple inclusions.
So you just need to remember this incantation,
every header will be surrounded by this.
Now, our header files can contain documentation,
it can contain prototypes,
which are function declarations,
it can contain constant definitions
that are used in multiple files or multiple functions,
it can contain class or structure definitions,
it can contain something called a template,
and it can contain global variable declarations,
that's the ones with the extern, you remember,
not global variable definitions.
The things that it may not contain in a header file
are function or variable definitions,
or using namespace standard.
That cannot go in the interface file.
So, we're going to add three functions to our header.
GCD, for the greatest common divisor,
yeah, greatest common divisor, Euclid's algorithm,
square root, for Newton's square root,
and pi.
So that's the prototype.
Notice that it ends in a semicolon.
Here's the double square root,
ends in a semicolon,
and here's pi.
It's going to take a numerator and a denominator,
and there is a parenthesis and a semicolon
at the end right here.
I apparently did not color them correctly on the slide.
So let's go ahead and add those.
So here's our prototypes.
So int GCD, int A, and int B,
and double square root, double n,
and void pi with an unsigned reference n
and an unsigned reference d,
and a semicolon.
Okay, so now we've got our prototypes in our interface,
but we might actually have a problem.
Do you recognize what the problem is?
Well, we have two square root functions.
The library already has a square root function,
and so if we tried to compile the code
with our version of square root
and the version of square root that the library already has,
the compiler would give us an error.
It would say we have a name clash or a name collision.
Okay, a name collision.
And so the solution to these name collisions,
and the reason that namespaces were invented,
is to put our functions in their own namespace.
We'll name our namespace A A for ancient algorithms.
Now, we're going to need to do this
both in the implementation and in the interface,
both in the header file and in the CPP file.
And that just looks like namespace A A,
an open brace, a closing brace,
and I actually don't think we need the semicolon.
I'm going to leave it off just to see.
So I'm going to say namespace A A,
and I'm going to put a closing brace on it.
Okay, so there is my declaration file,
my declaration file, or my interface file.
Now, the client file is the one that calls or tests the functions.
In the CS course reader, in the course reader you're going to read,
you'll learn to do this manually.
And we kind of learned to do it in the first couple weeks,
where you wrote code,
you wrote, figured out what the output would be for your IPO programs,
and you figured out what the expected output should be,
for different inputs.
We're going to do this using the CS150 automated test framework.
And so here's the framework process for testing.
You write a function called,
so let me go over here to my code,
and we'll look at the tester.
Let me move that over in second place here.
So one thing you do is you include this header file
for the functions that are in the test function,
and then you include the header for the functions that need to be tested.
So I will give you this file with run tests in it,
and all you'll need to do is add the include for the functions you're going to test.
So let's go ahead, since we're testing this, let's put our ID here.
Then inside the function run tests,
you will have a begin tests.
This will begin all the tests you're going to do,
and at the very end you'll have an end tests.
For each function you're going to test,
you'll write a function called begin function test.
So this is the test for GCD.
This is the test for square root Newton's method,
and this is the test for pi approximate.
And so that will begin function test and end function test,
and that will create the tests for that.
Now in between this, you'll use different versions of what are called assert equals.
So this is the version of assert equals.
Those are in this header file.
So this is assert equals for integers.
So we're going to say when we call our GCD function with 12 and 90,
we expect to get back 6 as the greatest common divisor.
If we call it with 42 and 56, we expect to get back 14,
and if we call it with 56 and 42, we expect to get back 14.
Notice these two are the same, but I've just exchanged them.
For Newton's square root method,
we're going to have to call a different version of assert equals,
one that checks doubles, and that checks using an epsilon value here.
So notice I've set up epsilon 10 e to the minus 4th,
and I'm checking the expected value, calling the function,
and passing in how close they have to be before they're equal.
And finally, for the last one, we're going to call assert equals.
We're going to do it for integers again,
but we're calling one where we're calling a procedure,
and we're testing two things.
So I'm calling the function with pi.
I'm calling our function pi.
I'm setting the variables n and d to 355, 113.
Then I have a comma, and this is the value I'm checking against this assert equals.
So you don't have to memorize these,
but I wanted you to see what the test program looks like.
What a test program looks like.
So you can use this to write your own tests.
So let's go ahead.
Where are we here?
Let's close each of these bath shells,
and let's go ahead and go to Algolib here
and open an integrated folder there.
So we're in Algolib, and we're going to do make tester.
So notice I'm not doing make test.
I don't even have a make file yet.
I'm doing make tester, which is going to compile this program.
And when I do, notice that there are no red things here.
All of these are linker errors.
It cannot find the function in function start.
It doesn't have the main function in function run tests.
It can't find begin tests.
And so what that tells you,
the fact that we only got linker errors here,
is that this code compiles without any compile errors.
So we only got linker errors there.
We didn't get any compile errors.
So again, to use the framework,
we include the header for the functions we're testing.
We place our testing code between begin function test
and end function test.
And then we use one of the different assert equals varieties
that you can see in tester.cpp.
And so when we did make tester, again, we got linker errors,
but no compiler errors.
If we had not written the header file,
we would get compiler errors.
And just to show you that that's true,
let's come over here,
and let's comment out that algo.h that we just wrote.
And let's do make tester again.
So I'll control L and do make tester.
And now notice all the red errors.
It doesn't know what aa square root is.
So now we have a whole bunch of compiler errors.
Compiler errors.
Before, we did not because we told the compiler here
inside algo.h what each function took as an argument
and what it returned.
Even though we don't have the function yet,
we declared them.
That's all the compiler needs to do to compile tester.cpp.
And just to show you, I'm going to clear this once again.
So if I say g++-c, I'm saying only compile,
tester.cpp, notice I get no errors or no warnings.
It compiles and produces tester.o for us.
Okay, so now we're ready to go on to step three.
We've written two of those files.
The client file, I actually wrote it for you, of course.
You added a little bit of code.
And the header file.
And so now we're ready to add the implementation.
Now the implementation is going to go in the cpp file.
And so there are five steps that you will want to memorize.
You will always want to start with the stubs or skeletons.
So add, include, header.
Notice the double quotes.
So this will be include algo.h.
Add any other headers needed to implement your code.
You can use using namespace standard in the cpp file.
It cannot go in the header file.
It can go in the cpp file.
Copy the prototypes and the namespace from the header file.
Remove the semicolons, add the body,
and the return statements.
So let's go ahead and do that stubbing step.
So we will come over here to algo.cpp.
We will include algo.h.
Do we need to use any library functions?
Well, we might need to use something.
So let's assume we need to use something in C math.
And because I want to use some of the functions in C math,
let's assume I want the using namespace standard.
Now I'm going to go back to algo.h.
I'm going to copy everything in the namespace.
I'm going to come to my -- let me move my tester down to the bottom there.
I'm going to come back here.
I'm going to paste it in there.
And now I'm just going to come remove the semicolons from the prototypes,
put in a body,
and for those functions that need to return something,
I'm just going to return a double value,
or I'm just going to return a dummy value.
So I'll say return zero, and I'll say return zero here.
Okay, so this is a void function,
so you notice I don't need to return anything for that.
Now you might think right now that this code would build,
but it still doesn't build because we need one more file.
We need a file to put everything together, and that is the make file.
So the make file is the cross-platform builder file.
It's instructions to a program called make.
Cross-platform means that it works on Windows, it works on Unix, it works on the Mac.
Now it's true that different platforms like Visual Studio on Windows,
or I can't remember the name of the compiler framework on the Mac, Xcode.
Each of those platforms have their own builder programs
and their own format for the files,
but this one works on every platform.
So make is worth using.
Now lately, people have started using another program called CMake.
What CMake does, it's also a cross-platform builder,
is CMake will create for you make files,
or if you're on Visual Studio, it'll create Visual Studio projects.
If you're on Xcode, it'll create Xcode projects.
I think in this class, we're simply going to stick with make
because it's easier to learn than CMake, I believe.
CMake is a little bit more complex.
If you want to learn more about CMake, you can look at the videos I have on the homepage,
the ones from the guy from British Columbia,
and he has quite a bit on using CMake if you want to learn that.
So here's what goes in a make file.
There are three parts.
There are the variables that describe what the inputs and outputs are.
There are rules that are used to combine those variables to produce the inputs and output,
and then the actions that are used.
So variables, rules, and actions.
So the first variables, these are actually technically called macros,
but we'll just think of them as variables,
is the name for our executable and the name for our object files.
So let's go over to our make file,
and let's put them inside here.
By the way, comments in make files are just the pound sign, like that.
So we will create a variable for our exe,
and we will say the exe, I'm going to call this algo_tester.
So you can have dashes inside there if you want.
That's the name of the executable.
The objects are algo.o.
So for every CPP file, you're going to create an object file.
So algo.o, cs150check.o, and tester.o.
So each of these is going to be separately compiled,
and then they'll be linked together when we put in our rule.
So our second step is the rule to build the target.
So our target is going to be our executable.
To expand that variable, or to play that macro,
what we do is we put it in a parenthesis and precede that by a dollar sign.
So in our case, we could type it out manually,
but nobody does because then you have to type it out manually all throughout the program.
So our target and dependency, our target here, is going to be the executable.
That's what we want to build.
And our dependency is going to be the object files, objs.
Again, in parenthesis, preceded by a dollar sign.
So this says to build this executable, algo tester,
we need to build first algo.o, cs150check.o, and tester.o.
Make knows how to build those, provided we have the CPP files for them.
The third step is the actions.
So the actions all proceed with a tab character.
Can't use a space here. If you use a space, you'll get an error.
So press your tab key.
And you notice it showed a little tab character.
Press your tab key.
And we're going to run a variable called cxx.
Where'd cxx come from?
We created it in the environment when we first set up our program.
We're then going to pass a second variable.
This is called cxxflags.
Where did that come from?
Again, we set that up when we set up our program.
And you can actually see what they are.
Echo $cxx, it's g++, and echo $cxxflags.
And you can see it's this long string that we created when we set up our program.
When you ran the 150 config file at the beginning of the class.
So these are the commands that we use to link our program together and build our program.
Then the inputs are going to be our object files.
So objs.
And then we have a dash lowercase o.
That's saying that's what the output is going to be.
And the output is going to be our executable.
So once we've done that, once we've done that.
We can come down here and say make.
And it will run each of those steps.
It will create alga.o.
It will create cs150check.o.
It will create tester.o.
It will link those three together.
And it will produce the output.
It will produce the output algo.tester.
So that built our program.
Now we would really like to say make test.
And for that we need one more step, a fourth step.
And that's to build a pseudo target.
So a pseudo target, the target part, is not something that gets built.
Inside the actions we don't build something like the executable.
We run something here.
So I'm going to run the executable.
And I'm going to pass -t to it.
And that is just what the framework uses to say, oh run the tests instead of run the program.
And so again with my last one I'm going to add a pseudo target here.
So I'm going to say test.
Test depends on the executable existing.
And I'm going to tab.
And I'm going to do ./ meaning look in the current directory.
Run the executable.
And then space -t test that current file.
Now -t is not a common thing.
It's what our test framework is using to test.
Once you've done that we can come over here and we can say make test.
Just like you can with your homework.
So notice we have the three tests that were written in the program.
Checking the GCD, checking the square root, checking pi approximate.
What was expected but what our programs found.
Remember we returned zero in each of those cases.
Okay so now let's look at implementing these three algorithms.
And then we'll look at documenting them and generating the documentation.
So GCD was developed by Euclid about 300 BC.
And if you look at the slides there's a Wikipedia link if you want to read more about it.
His essential insight was that if I have two numbers, the divisor of a larger number and a smaller number.
That that divisor is going to be the same as the divisor of the smaller number and the larger minus the smaller.
In other words by essentially repeatedly subtracting over and over again.
I can get to the smallest combination of a and b that have the same divisor.
And so when one of these a or b gets to zero then the other one is just going to be the smaller divisor.
So that means we have to repeat. We have to do it once. So we're going to do that with a loop.
We're reducing to zero so we have a limit loop.
So here's the pseudocode for the algorithm GCD a b.
Now it really doesn't matter with this algorithm whether a or b is smaller.
Because unlike Euclid who originally used subtraction where it makes quite a bit difference that you divide the...
you subtract the smaller from the larger.
We're going to use remainder.
And remainder works regardless of which one is smaller and larger.
So this is the algorithm while b is not zero. A limit loop.
Let temp be b. Let b be a. Remainder b.
And then a equal the temp one.
And then at the end GCD will be the a.
So let's go ahead and implement that.
We'll implement it and we'll test it.
So let's minimize that.
Let's go to algo.cpp.
So we'll say while b is not equal to zero.
We'll say temp equals b.
b equals a remainder b.
And a equals temp.
And then at the end we're going to return a.
a is going to be the smaller of those two.
Or it's going to be the result.
So let's try it.
Let's go ahead and clear this up again.
And do make test once again.
And we'll see that for our GCD a...
our a a GCD we in fact got the correct values for all of this.
So that one worked.
The second algorithm we want to look at
is Newton's square root method.
So this is as I mentioned attributed to Isaac Newton.
But it's actually recorded in cuneiform
from ancient Babylon, the Hammurabi dynasty about 17 or 1800 BC.
And it's recorded in base 60 numbers.
So we've looked at base 10, base 2, base 8, and base 16.
These were in base 60.
And this algorithm also uses a limit loop.
It's an approximation algorithm.
With an approximation algorithm you take two guesses
and then you do a function on those two guesses
until the difference is close enough.
So here's the algorithm.
You make a new guess as to the root of n.
It doesn't matter what the guess is.
Most people do n divided by 2.
Then you write a loop.
So we're going to loop. We're going to set the old guess to the new guess.
We're going to set new guess to n divided by the old guess
plus the old guess and all of that divided by 2.
So this is the part that I don't know how they figured out, but they did.
And we're going to keep doing that until the difference
between the guesses is less than epsilon.
So let's go ahead and implement and test that.
So let's minimize that.
And let's look at the square root function.
So what we want to do is we want to make a new guess
for the root of n.
So double new guess equals n divided by 2.
It wouldn't really matter what you set it to.
Now we're going to write a loop.
So this loop is going to use a do while loop.
So we're going to say do while.
The difference between the guesses is less than epsilon.
So for the difference we're going to take the absolute value
of new guess minus old guess.
And until it is less than epsilon.
So while it is greater or equal to k epsilon,
we'll keep going.
Now of course my code doesn't compile now because some of those things I don't have.
So first notice that I'm checking these two variables new guess minus old guess.
My algorithm says in the loop I'm setting old guess equal to new guess.
You might be tempted to do this.
Double old guess new guess.
The problem is that your code won't compile.
Because old guess will not be in scope.
It will be created here and go out of scope at that point.
And so it will not be created.
So we have to create old guess up here.
Double old guess.
And we might just set it to new guess.
Or set it to zero. It doesn't make any difference.
And so inside the loop we have to set old guess equal to new guess.
Now this still won't compile because we don't know what k epsilon is.
So let's create k epsilon here.
So const double k epsilon.
Equals we'll do 1.0 e to the minus 14.
So we'll say that's if it's closer than that it's close enough for our work.
Finally one more step here in our algorithm from the slides.
Is we're going to set new guess.
Equal to n divided by old guess.
Plus old guess.
All of that divided by two.
And finally rather than returning zero of course we're going to return either new guess or old guess.
They are functionally identical here.
So we'll return new guess.
Okay so here's our algorithm for square root.
Let's go ahead and try that.
Make test.
And here our square root is working.
Of course I checked something that wasn't very complex.
We would actually like to check something a little more complex.
If we were doing this you know outside of a classroom situation.
The third algorithm we're going to look at.
Is finding a approximation for pi.
So pi is an irrational number.
That means there is no rational number.
Irrational means a ratio.
So there is no fraction that represents pi.
And so about 1650 BC.
So in 16 BC, 17 BC, 18 BC in Egypt they used 19 over 6.
That's the Ames papyrus.
In Babylon they used 25 over 8 as the number for pi.
Archimedes in 150 BC recognized that pi was irrational.
And it was between two fractions.
Between 223 over 71 and 220 over 70.
In the first century Ptolemy thought he got a little bit closer.
He used 377 over 120.
Ptolemy is famous of course you remember for the person who thought that the sun went around the earth.
And finally in the 5th century in China.
This emperor whose name I'm not even going to try and pronounce.
I'm going to call him Su.
Came up with the number 355 over 113.
And that was the approximation we want to try and beat.
So our goal is to find a better approximation than Su.
And so like the Newton's algorithm.
This is going to be an approximation algorithm.
We're going to try something, see if we get a better one.
Try it again, see if we get a better one and so forth.
So we'll make an initial approximation.
While it isn't close enough we'll try and get closer.
Now to find out if it's close enough.
We have to have some way of checking what the actual value of pi is.
So this is called a test oracle.
And so we're going to use what our computer thinks pi is.
By using the libraries arc cosine of -1 as our test oracle for pi.
Then we'll use the absolute value of Su - pi as our epsilon value.
So let's go ahead and see if we can figure out that last one here.
Okay, now notice we're not going to return anything.
All we're going to do is change the values of n and d.
So let's create some constants.
So const double k Su equals 355.0 divided by.
And I forgot from my slide what it was.
355 by 113.
Okay, and so our k pi, const double k pi is going to equal a cosine -1.
So this will be our oracle.
For our epsilon, const double k epsilon, we'll use the absolute value of k Su - k pi.
And we're going to use a while loop.
So we're going to guess what our approximation is.
So that's going to be double approx equals n divided by d.
Now we have a problem.
n is an unsigned number, d is an unsigned number.
This is undoubtedly going to be wrong.
So we need to convert these to doubles.
So I need to say static cast double n.
Now you don't need to convert it.
It will implicitly convert d to a double if one of the arguments in here is a double.
Now notice you could not do this.
You need to do one of the arguments.
So that wouldn't help you at all, right?
Because you've already divided n divided by d before you cast it to a double.
So you need to do it like this.
You need to cast one of the arguments.
And some people are trying to add a multiplication in there.
So 1.0 times n divided by d would work just as well.
It would cast that value to a double.
It would promote it.
So that's our approximation.
So make an additional approximation.
So while the difference between our approximation minus k pi is greater or equal to k epsilon,
we want to get closer.
We want to get it less than epsilon.
Less than epsilon.
So to get it less than, we're going to find out if our approximation is greater than pi or less than pi.
So if approximation is greater than k pi, then what we want to do is make the number smaller.
And we make the number smaller by adding to the denominator.
So if that is the case, we're going to say d plus plus.
We're going to add one to the denominator.
And if it's not greater than pi, we're going to add one to the numerator, n plus plus.
I'm missing my semicolons there.
Put it in there, then took it out.
So that's how we're going to move it, get closer to getting closer to this.
So now we need to calculate the approximation again.
Now that we've changed the difference of values in n and d.
So we'll say approximation equals static cast double n over d.
And now we'll keep going through there until this is true.
Or until that is false.
Until that is false.
Until absaprox minus k pi is less than k epsilon.
So let's try our third test here.
Okay, and our last time checking pi approximate shows that the fraction should be the next closer one to pi than 355 over 113 is 52,162 over 16,604.
So here's the pi value.
Here's what 355 over 113 gives me.
And this is our new value that's a little closer.
Notice that pi is actually, we're a little less than pi.
This was a little greater than pi.
But we're still closer to pi than that one was.
That one was.
Okay, so that's all the tests.
The last thing we want to do is we want to look at documenting our code.
So we're going to use javadoc style function comments similar to what we used with java.
Now the tool we're going to use is not javadoc, it's this program called doxygen.
You place these in your header file.
And you will always have in every header file a file comment with @file.
And you'll have a namespace comment.
So let me show you what those look like.
So let me minimize that.
Let me go to algo.h.
So I've already put the file comment here.
I've put the @author.
And I've put the @version here already.
And we already filled that in.
Now in front of the namespace we're going to do slash, star, star.
And I'm simply going to describe in one sentence what this is.
The ancient algorithms library.
So that's documenting my namespace.
Notice I have to use backspace so that I can do slash, star.
If you don't do backspace, notice that this isn't highlighted again.
It's not highlighted correctly.
So I need to do backspace there to get the slash, star.
So this is the file comment.
This is the namespace comment.
Then in front of each function we're going to add a function comment.
So again, slash, star, star, and ending with star, slash.
Slash, star, star, ending with star, slash.
So that's the basic structure.
It will always start with a single line that describes what it does and ends in a period.
So calculates the greatest common divisor, period.
This one is going to calculate the square root using Newton's method.
And this one is going to calculate a better approximation for pi than 355 over 113.
Again, ending with a period.
Now for each parameter, you will create a param tag.
And the param tag looks like this.
It's @param, then the name of the parameter, a, and then description, the first number.
@param b, the second number.
So we'll do the same thing for this. @param n, the number, the process.
And for this one, we have @param n, the initial numerator.
I always spell numerator as a numberator. @param d, the initial denominator.
Then, so we've got the, we've got the file comment, we've got the param tag,
we're going to add a return tag describing what's returned.
So this function does @return.
I'm the greatest common advisor of a and b.
And this returns @return the square root of n.
And this one doesn't return anything, it's a void function, so we don't have to say anything about that.
Finally, we can add code segments.
So those will be syntax highlighted in the generated documentation.
So this starts with @code and ends with @encode.
Make sure you put the @encode in or your comments will not be processed.
So we'll say example@code.cpp @encode.
And we'll say double root equals a square root of 3.5.
And for the GCD, let's add an example there.
Example@code.cpp and @encode.
And let's say, let's look at some of our tests so we can, in our test, 12 to 90.
[ Typing Sounds ]
Okay, so give them an example of what's happening.
And for the last one, calling it code@cpp @encode.
Let's do unsigned, n equals zero, d equals zero.
And this is pi, n and d.
And what did it equal?
52, 163.
N is 52, 163.
And d is 16, 604.
Okay, so there is our comments.
You can take a picture of the comments for the, as one of the things you're going to do for your, for your in-class exercise.
There's a place where they want you to shoot a picture of the comments.
Okay, the last picture we want to take is we want to turn this into HTML documentation.
And for that, we're going to use a tool called Doxygen.
Now, we do not yet have that on this platform.
It was on the previous one we used.
But what we're going to do, no worries, we're just going to install it.
So to install it, go to your shell and type in sudo, that means do something as the super user, apt-get install doxygen.
And that will read the package lists and if it's already installed, which I've already did it earlier, it will say, you know, it's already here.
If it's not installed, it will say, do you want to install this? It will use so many megabytes.
Click yes and install it.
Once you've installed it, you're going to create a file called the doxy file.
Notice I'm in my algol lib file and again you only have to do this once.
So I'm going to say doxygen -g and that will generate this file called a doxy file.
Then open up the doxy file and go through it, the instructions here, and change each of these lines and save it.
Finally, once you've done that, so assuming you've got doxygen, you've opened your doxy file, you've saved your doxy file,
to generate your documentation, you're going to say doxygen doxy file, just like that.
That is going to look on the left hand side in my algolib folder, you'll see that it created a new folder called html here.
In the html folder, there's a folder called search.
In the search folder, there's a folder called index.html.
Here's index.html in the html folder.
So I'm going to close the search folder and find index.html here.
What I want to do is I want to preview this.
So to preview it, what I'm going to do is I'm going to right click and open that search folder.
Actually I didn't want search, let me close that bash shell.
And let me close that bash shell.
And it will open up a new terminal on the html, open an integrated terminal.
So now I'm on the html folder, and what I want to do is I want to look at this folder.
And to do that, because I'm already on the internet, I have to run another web server.
So I'm going to run the program called http-server.
This was installed with our IDE here.
And notice that's starting a little web server.
And if I control click on this link, it will open that up in my browser.
And I can click on index.html.
Now of course, normally what you do with this documentation is you put it out on the web.
So this is the documentation for our ancient algorithms library.
We're going to click on the namespace.
And here is our AA, the ancient algorithms library.
You remember when we put this in our comments.
I'm going to click on that.
And notice that's telling me the functions inside that.
So notice it's got three functions, gcd, square root, and pi.
This is the output that I produced for this.
And so notice the examples and everything that people can read.
So this is how you generate documentation for your users to use.
Okay, so that's it with this lecture.
I'll see you when we come back for the next one.